citizens of the reject Nation it is time to make
it to our third part of the Final Destination it's
Final Destination three where are we going
we're gonna go on the roller coaster of Love
Today roller coaster okay you predicted Highway to
Hell I'm predicting roller coaster of love let's
see if that's true I see roller coaster I think
it's fun family movie probably gonna be their
first comedy in the franchise a first comedy in
these past two have been hilarious yeah all the
physical comedy that you told me would be there
you guys like these movies as much as we do and
you like that we're doing these reactions don't
forget to like this video subscribe all that good
stuff also if you want to get the full length
Reaction watch along then make sure you can
sync up with us if you go to patreon.com the real
rejects Greg and John are covering several shows
exclusively over there with reaction highlights
and watch alongs included those are all the super
checks are oh yeah oh yeah the way that you are
rubber chickening your neck right now I didn't
stretch here we go I want her to wish your grandma
a happy birthday it's my Grammy's 96th birthday
she's going there immediately after this yeah I
am so she thought she should get a horror show
and right before going to see her grandparents
she wanted cotton pajamas oh he's so sweet so
that's exactly what she'll get happy birthday okay
but did you hear my third time's a charm reference
like that was a great transition that you I might
have been so focused on making sure I got my thing
in there that I didn't quite but good job because
I found this in three so third time's a charm now
[Music]
guess who's back crack it rocks air
pack tell a friend you tell all your
friends all your friends tweet it
out recommend this video perhaps
you're stoked we're at the theme park
theme park let's go roll the coaster
[Music]
this is gonna cool intro this is way more
horror like I feel like this is it vibes
the tarot cards [Music] Mary Elizabeth
Winstead is in this I love her [Music]
so you directed this because this looks really
good bright colors different more pup [Music] oh
boy the anxiety of a theme park I think it's
a carnival yeah definitely James Wong [Music]
oh James won co-wrote it cool
James long is back to direct it
so he did all three of these so
far he did the first one and and
he didn't do the second one oh
I love these rides they tell you
to scream on the way up to tighten
your stomach so it doesn't drop as
much that is a scary shot [Applause]
kid on the right what is his name
he's Texas long bottom or whatever
that guy's name very very famous we are
gonna get annihilated for that [Music]
what do you see no way hot die yeah die and to
feel how that would be to crash and burn like that
oh what TV show is it Dawson's Creek or what he
who is it yeah he looks like he's played a really
nice guy before or a douchebag 7th Heaven
no he's won one of those shows we watched
growing up oh what doesn't kill you makes you
stronger man never heard that one before yeah
I love how the main characters are always
in the situations where they're with their
friends and it's the most terrifying
situation beforehand for them so this
can be a carnival right carnivals don't
have roller coasters like that it's a
movie Carnival come on it's not
even mine Kevin is the yearbooks
upskirting women is a big No-No these
are for the yearbook I doubt it if a
shot of Stacy kobiatch is camel
to make it in there I buy two
we got the Bros back can you make
me crazy I'm breaking up with him
get it girl aha you don't need no man now that's
right there that'll sell some yearbooks One Tree
Hill no no he does look familiar I think he's in
another horror movie I love the 2000s songs out
same as the exact things uh the
last two focusing on weird images
oh my God I do miss carnivals haven't
been to one in a long time you've got
to stop calling in a carnival though
but it's a carnival how is it a carnival
like what about the pier what do you
call the Santa Monica Pier I back off
that's so fair here we go
oh my God is here token black guy
that's what I'm talking about oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no oh no
I thought it was going to decapitate me
transcending became one with you say no no
there it is awesome there it is stop the jams
look at the nipples on that dear devil this is a
really nice Carnival this is a carnival the prizes
and or it could be the pier they say the real
fear with these rides comes from the feeling of
having no control so dude another horror movie
you made me watch what movie if the newspaper
in the family and they're
dead that was Ethan Hawk phone
have you ever seen that no exit after
Turn Style yeah something along those
lines okay so which of your her
friends do you think are gonna
die first ooh probably her best friend
the girl who's gonna dump the dude yeah
you see I think James Wong is
is a much better composer with
his frames like there's much more sharp Direction
roller coaster is just Elemental physics a
conversion of potential energy to kinetic
energy yeah odds are like one in 250 million
of dying in a roller coaster oh my God are you
ever dead you're more likely to die driving to an
amusement park than dying at one that's true those
are some amusement parks amusement park is an
amusement park damn it would you tell me back off
[Music]
a guy from the other horror movie you made me
watch The Descent now that it was all women
I like this Frankie cheats is old school
ladies what's that oh well it'd be my honor
oh oh I hated that this guy is a repulsive
I can't sit in the front I cannot see the
tracks oh freak oh Carol's in the back
with you right babe because we're girls
oh no whoever sits with her is going to
live whoever doesn't is gonna die all
right you know what we'll just settle this
like real man how about that call it heads
[__] they found out he died in the newspaper
I won't figure it out later hey just do me a
favor keep an eye on her okay she's just kind of
freaked out oh cool yeah I have no idea that's why
he's going back because he's the most famous
one okay so can't kill him yeah in the movie
that's a devil number baby devil
cool shot here we go hey Jay keep your hands to
yourself man I'm serious payback's a [__] God
damn you now I'm like trying to figure out oh no
what's happening what's happening he sneaks in now
get in the back oh now they're
gonna live or are we gonna see
the death thing happen and then they never get on
hey how'd you guys get in here come on
you too that's an interesting detail
about those little kids what do you think
that has to do with it yeah I'm curious too
what's up man I'm good oh yes it was dripping
blood it looks like it how do you do on roller
coasters I used to be great now I'm terrible loser
what I'm just kidding is this this is gonna be an
enjoyable reaction I'm my chest just hurts now
whenever I'm on a roller coaster I get it oh ew
ew
[Music] [Applause] [Music]
maybe once we get back to this if they don't get
on the kids do get to stay on or something and
then the kids die I don't know that was
a really interesting [Applause] [Music]
details are acting like this is the
roller coaster of the century it's
exciting everyone's like this is the most
exact thing ever every time I've been in
a roller coaster we're just like all right
let's just go my mom used to put cardboard
in my shoes so I'd be tall enough to ride the
rides I wonder how safe that was horrified
this looks just like Colossus or Goliath yeah
I wonder where they shot this or also you
wonder how many times they had to shoot these
scenes I know right [Music] [Applause] cool
this is a really well
captured roller coaster scene
a good time
they could be just setting us up right
now yeah they just get off the road
oh
the Pervert cost them
that is so scary yeah that
is terrifying that is scary
Goosebumps
so cows are gonna stop oh Jesus
oh no oh no that is so scary they
do a great job of taking what are
some people's biggest fears and making
them the beginning of their movies yeah
oh my God he's holding on grab
him grab him oh no his legs
[Music]
was this all because of the camera or there
was like 80 things that happened yeah
there's the pipe bursting too [Music]
oh Jesus oh my God [Music]
I'll be rocking whoa they really hung
those people there how many Rockets smart
oh no that is so scary
[Music]
sit down sit down [Music]
there we go okay read oh well I'll
just I'll put in my pocket yeah
all right let's do this wait what are you
you know that honestly might have been
the scariest one to me yeah because it's
so many people's irrational fear [Music]
I am so glad they got married Elizabeth
Winstead she is such a great actress yeah
she's really good my head the tracks collapse
the rollercoaster no she was just a little
upset before man please can you please control
that [__] oh damn damn dude unless he just
trying to get some [__] attention you
know what you're a real piece of [__]
Louis [__] you damn it [__] you oh great the
franchise is full of the most insensitive people
dude let me off I gotta make sure she's
okay oh this poor guy let's go bummer
not for long that's sad this is what you get for
not sitting with your girlfriend yeah [Music]
call your mother they're about
to watch everybody start falling
wow good one damn this is good franchise
yeah that's what I told you I know and I
agreed that's what I said and then you also said
it and then I said it again we're on the same page
I have a feeling I'm gonna connect a little bit
more to these characters yeah I'm already in on
them I really cared about that situation when
he he couldn't get off of the roller coaster
did it say how long after this is
not yet oh he's in the locker I'm
telling you he was in the newspaper I didn't
believe you we'll look it up later [Music]
oh come on give me the
exposition it's been six months
it wasn't for you and Jay being
friends me and Carrie being friends
we wouldn't have even hung out but now you're
gonna be lovers wow that's cold you better get it
we're ready for graduation tonight we're going
to the tanning salon after this and we are so
totally cool if you want to come with oh you know
there's going to be a 10 in Salon death you get
stuck in there and burned to death yes if you're
not alone oh God I appreciate everyone trying
to help okay I really do no we tap in before
okay I went online looking for an explanation
I like him I know I like them both they really
have a lot of angry women in their franchise men
write it I went on a trip to Paris when they were
boarding a kid had a vision that the plane was
gonna explode you know in the next several months
everyone who got off that plane started dying in
weird accidents they died in the order they would
have if they stayed on the plane I I'm liking this
the characters more do they not know about the car
accident one too I guess not the most televised
one was the flight 180. also what did he Google
to get that has this ever happened before yeah
that was a popular incident
this one's a story about grief
flamma ball how can we go for like a tune-up
I just want to make sure that we look our
best yeah you know for all those kids that
died that night we'll never get a graduation
have you ever gone on a tanning bed no no have
you way too many times when I was a kid they're
actually very relaxing I guess unless they explode
well watch this movie let's see what happens
bracelet that grandma left me in her will Julie
you're not really mad with each other I could
use some help yeah I can't talk I love it you're
all I have left maybe you could come stay with
me for what you know I will oh yes yes sister
keep this now and I'll get it when I come see
you I forget was she on the ride I know she
was questioning that right now too I can remember
can I use a school camera for graduation tonight
actually the battery is pretty low so why don't
you go get ready and I'll recharge it a bit
the upskirting not drinks
in the room this time okay
very 2000s
what he's gonna get stuck outside and
he's not gonna be able to help them
I am really enjoying the refinement
aspects of the execution of this
[Music] no don't go above 12 minutes honey what
a horrible thing to have happen and
I don't even know what happened yet
what what is gonna happen he's gonna
not be able to open the door it's gonna
get stuck and they're gonna be stuck in
the machines and they can't get them out
and they're gonna like burn to death
at least one of them maybe we'll see
what does you see
what I don't know what that means she literally
touched it I still don't know what it was dude you
said he said no drinks if you spill that [__]
we're gonna have to clean it up like last time
maybe it's just we called her from machines
or whatever a few degrees won't hurt
I've never been into a salon with two in one room
oh great it's so bad for you kids
will be kids teens will be teens Greg
Potter
I feel like there's gonna be
some like insane domino effect
yet again [Music] those two interesting
things I think there's interesting things
in this franchise for sure well booby never
heard anything sometimes I just can't take
my eyes off the screen you know because you
got you can't miss anything I just can't miss
any detail you never know what's gonna happen
you just gotta look maybe we should rewind it
oh this is going to be disturbing
I can really feel this [Music]
let the fun begin oh no
their plate is off here yeah
I hate you you're looking at one yeah I said
it I was looking at something else on screen
okay you got Highway to Hell I got roller
coaster of Love wow you really called it
does that mean that we are predicting
the future and therefore are we gonna
have something happens if the
producer's still watching this
can you put us in Final Destination six
please and thank you thank you [Music]
oh no this is gonna be so gross oh I
oh no yeah with the goggles too it's
creepy this is a really smart move
of theirs of the of the movie not the
girls I think it's a great combination
of both whoa cool shot sorry the battery's
totally dead camera's not working sorry
Julie I need a minute okay take Grandma's
necklace back [Music] I just gotta call him
we're the acid Player rock
goes for love later in the
movies that's pretty gnarly that is
you said it too hot in here [Music]
oh
okay oh no death you genius this
is Wendy give me a call whenever
you guys are done and thanks again for the invite
stay calm sorry I was too late you can
cool your body down with meditation [Music]
oh no you can't slide out of there
Greg
oh God [Music]
they're not gonna look good for graduation
[Music]
that was whoa great match cut you see that
damn that was horrifying I know oh my God Greg
the end of the nudity yes that was the sad part
we are all equal in death's eyes they just like
dress the same everywhere they go all of us
how can you say that shut up dude I think it's
true Charlie Manson minute to 70. Osama let's go
still kicking pimps nope we got him got his ass
these two girls who never done [__] to anybody
they don't get to make it to 18. yeah Fine Mary
Elizabeth Winston wants to get off the ride says
she's a [__] who wants attention guy freaks out
at a funeral yeah come on bro let's go this is
so my fault seeing women is nothing but fun bags
buy the scene there whatever Humanity
they wouldn't have felt the pressure to
look so good and press Franklin cheeks
she looks like Jennifer Love Hewitt be
proud of your ability to make everything
that happens somehow a story about you
oh my God
that was great that was so funny yeah man I
think just James really knows how to capture
the colors of movies man this looks so
good hey if you ever have to come to
my funeral and bring me a PSP or something
at least I have something to do then hello
do you think they're gonna fall in love
we haven't had that happen full blown yet
it'd be a little disrespectful huh I don't
know man works in mysterious ways I didn't
want to upset anyone by being there and I
wondered if maybe here I could feel Chase
Spirit or presence if there's any place that
makes you feel like there's no life after death
huh yeah I haven't felt Carey's spirit
either I tried your conversation
there's just to get me on the ride he said your
fear is from a sense of having no control and I
felt that fear since the moment he said
it's like a presence like a living thing
always with me remember Carrie was gonna
break up with him yeah yeah he hasn't even
she hasn't even mentioned that yeah she will
in a mean moment it's cold and terrifying
trippy so trying to think about the roller coaster
who should be next then the two girls and then the
guy who was videotaping them the one who just
tried to kiss yeah yeah probably although he
took the he took her their spaces yeah so really
would they be next they were last no but remember
originally they were behind the two girls and
then the guy jumped in front of them and took
their spaces I don't remember well enough yeah
to videotape them and that's when they moved to
the back where the kids were the photographic
plate was broken causing a line that can't be
removed exactly where he was shot what look see
the shadow well what do these pictures have to
do with us this occurred one year to the day of
the flight 180 says Hey part two but you can't
believe every weird thing out there because
you're desperate for an answer I took these
I don't get what you see
I'm totally missing whatever it is it's like an
image of it that's like a line these 180 degrees
so just a line oh I think is what she's saying
what's Frankie's picture look like it's right here
so [Applause] sorry I think death feels more
like a haunting looming presence in this one too
good advertisement this is donkeys yeah well
this is obvious he's falling off a ladder a
rope ladder though maybe he might hang oh okay
so in the pictures there's it alludes to how they
die okay yeah there's signs in there what like
he's gonna get crushed by a giant SpongeBob oh
hey SpongeBob lives underwater so sad that you
know that everybody knows that's the song what
was the 180 part though aren't those usually
on those big 18 wheelers yeah yeah I don't
see it in this picture anywhere though [Music]
all right yeah it's because he's not gonna get
killed by the 18 wheeler you guys were next I
feel like he's about to die what do you want
are you okay yeah we're in trouble yeah no they're
gonna get skipped over but it is coming right now
180 180 . this guy's way too close to
my truck too [__] close man pull up
oh death is having so much fun
oh [__] get out get out there's no one
in that truck what an insane domino effect
oh is that pervert guy in front of
them remember I told you they were next
foreign he's gonna die [Applause] kick
out kick out yep yep get out [Music]
it was perfect guy did you see him I saw
him but I don't think it was oh it was
good one so was it coming for pervert guy
or was it coming for that pervert guy but
but why then in the first movie was it
based on their original seats not the
seats that you sat in I have no idea
you know what I'm saying though yeah
we can walk to my house and then I'll give
you a ride to yours I think so we'll be okay
you know I feel like this one is doing the you
asked me in the last video what I wish the sequels
would do and this one's giving it to me like
there's more tension yeah and I care more yeah
no I don't care about the dots that's what you
were yeah well overall I do just care more about
everything but the characters care more about
the death yes I agree with you yeah okay easy
cool cool hand all right he was behind
Ashley and Ashland on the ride but there
was no ladder here you know there was
no rope nothing because this one was
coming for you guys it's better not
knowing no it's never better staying
ignorant willful ignorance is surrendering
control there's philosophy in this movie Man
oh tell him don't tell him tell him why would
you do that because then she could have a shot
yeah I was gonna ask her to marry me oh
really she was gonna break up with you
upskirt picture this picture shows how
he died all right go back to Louis the
weight looks like it's coming down on his
head this is so cool you got to interpret
photos oh that is really awesome agreed
look at these pictures of us in there
of course no no I don't want to see mine no but
you got to be able to if there's any way to beat
this thing I gotta stay focused and if I look
at that picture all I'm gonna do is obsess so
you know what no I don't want to see it weird
logic would you want to see I would want 100.
you all crack wait they're literally like
personal trainers who have died at the
gym from like weight lifting wrong
and an accident happening of course
all right I love the game of clues in this
one you both lost people real close to you
on the way and in order to feel less guilty
or whatever seeing signs and patterns man
does this say that something would smash
on his head based on the yeah it looked
like something was going to smash on his
head so they should be on the lookout for
something smashing on his head but that
would cut off his head enough yeah but
that's in the picture it's a mislead right
no they're just seeing that the Bears here
this is here you're here and Alive because of
her no I'm alive because of me you don't get
Rover the black guy really doesn't believe
talk about a vision I hope they save him in
four years from now lose a mirror going in
the second round stop 15 Seasons I can't get
over how great the direction is in this oh no
you think it's gonna happen yeah stop ew stop him
it's gonna fall on his head
oh no so there's a question
no this guy's open it says open I
thought no I do Kevin baby I just win
that was like the dentist scene for me just
why me all those people out there wanted to have
a premonition or see a ghost or whatever I don't
this one's like existential and reflective I
I like it a lot with stereotypical ensembles
getting killed off my head's not like through the
windshield or anything yeah crushed by a steering
wheel paled by gear shift he's definitely gonna
die in this movie just look at the photo man
yeah and then make out with her because that's
what I want I want it to happen they're both
really good looking yeah totally got those
Planet orders yet ah it's a big no pip Osama
setting off the alarms wow a couple of sama
references yeah I know this guy loves referencing
Osama it's the same guy who refers and we did
have a picture of the Twin Towers too babies yeah
oh that's cruel
oh I can't wait for you to die
now that's really cool what was
in his picture do you remember I
hope it's something horrible now
hi it's Wendy and Kevin he's
scared the [__] out of me
yeah wait till you hear what we have to tell you
you were scared before just wait till you
talk to us she'll be even more scared isn't
that exciting I'm gonna OD on nail polish
and Ian is gonna be embarrassed to death
what's happened to the others I mean you
just saw their pictures and that crazy
I feel like there's some theme
here about like surrendering
control or something are you guys
saying that death is like a person
goals no awareness that it is a force in
fact in past cases if the next in line
is safe what do you think about the
kids from the beginning still though
I guess there's nothing to them no
maybe they snuck on somewhere else
hey watch those boxes
freak the guy out like that you're gonna get
him killed death is just the end of biological
function it's as simple as that I definitely
met people like that guy yeah me too I was
just saying that what was this pigeon being shot
with the nail gun right now well that's how he's
gonna go he was eating french toast when Princess
Diana died in Paris and then he saw her funeral
on TV and now he's dead crazy so guess how you
do something wow death you are so clever I'm
done so I finished cutting those over so we
can get out of here okay what do you think's
Happening Here something with a nail gun right
yeah I think the nails are gonna get him somehow
do you not hear it falling they've
really amped up the domino effect here
like every death has had a very crazy order
of events that led to it maybe it's something
they have to die simultaneously if
they were sitting next to each other
oh yeah yeah maybe that's a good guess
oh because perfect guy was sitting alone
have you guys not hear any of
this I don't know [Music] foreign
I'm unclear on what but can't be good I love the
staging of these things what is the writer's room
like and then this happens and then this and then
this and then they die what if the last in line or
to make the utilitarian Choice kill themselves
[Music] good question that's pretty much gonna
ruin any planned that's put in motion and even
better okay he's Gonna Save I've skipped lives
but is she capable of doing that because in the
last movie they weren't the guy wasn't able to
death is always making an entrance
[Music] [Applause]
brutal
oh she's still breathing there's a lot there's
more dread to this that was gory I guess they
don't have to die at the same time do they believe
you would you believe me no they looked at me like
I was crazy for all we know whoever was sitting
behind there and is already dead and we're next
I think you're right I think it's a sister do
you think this is gonna have any tie into the
second one uh I mean they mentioned it briefly
the second one one when she was first pulling
up the photos she said this habit on the highway
what I mean is like referencing the second one how
the second one referenced the first one they
were all like a byproduct and they mentioned
the logs the situation the Highway Scene no I
get what you're saying I'm asking if we think
their deaths are impacted by the second movie's
deaths the way the second movie's deaths were
impacted by the first movie's deaths they
were showing uh like the highway sequence
in the second movie yeah no I think I don't
think they're gonna do that you don't know
Daniel thing and I could really use my goodness
I think it's how she's gonna find out her
sister's dead you think the somehow the
brace is going to lead to her death no I think
it's gonna be left over she knows it was her
sister who died because the rest of her body's
so mangled but she sees the bracelet all right
all right I'm not sure I like your guesses I
like where you're at I like the way you think
does she see the bracelet yeah man it's
the bracelet ah dude yeah you did good
you're doing good this thing oh a lot
of guesses right I don't know I'm kind
of a genius yeah kind of do you remember
Julie being on the roller coaster what
your sister no Amber or Perry were
probably with her so they're next
I'm here now working security did we know
he did that I know and yours is the picture
that I took when I flashed the camera in
your face it's all out of focus and over
the firework went off my face
you gotta clear up
here we go [Music]
it's all did you ever have to do the Rube
Goldberg projects in school no I wasn't as
talented as you you'd set like a domino and it
would hit to a string and the string would go to
or whatever like all the yeah yeah this is that
this is all about how death operates [Applause]
foreign [Applause] picture
other than her bracelet a hand
sweet you guys are tools get lost Mary and Pippin
oh wait wait maybe Julie lent her
bracelet to a friend I don't know
middle finger horse damn [Music]
ah bummer
it's not over it's not over foreign [Music]
yeah cut that string is that a real sword yeah
I love him I know he's about to die you have to
tell me to tell me who was sitting
next to you on the roller coaster
oh now the the horse is about to
kill one of her friends nobody
yeah there's nobody sitting next to
her no she's about to get oh [Music]
together Kevin yeah go get Kevin put it together
hick alone would have killed him [Music]
you should pull them out yeah I know but now it's
her I saved my life something McKinley let's see
that horse kick alone it is about McKinley
it's about the guy he's McKinley his name is
McKinley okay early on he said I can't believe
my name's the same name as the high school oh
yeah that's right get the [__] out of here
McKinley hey I'm just celebrating our towns
tricentennial oh that's right because
he believes to kill her yeah yeah yeah
for me it is awful I'm not
dying they say it saved you man
now if if it skips her it goes back to him right
oh this Fool's gonna think he's an immortal if it
skips you it will go right back
around it's you it's you Wendy
[Music]
oh they didn't see the movies we saw so they don't
know that it circles back
they don't know the rules
oh damn the sending's a little bit
more akin to the first one [Music]
blurry face what does blurry face mean that's
what was next to her and then this was just blurry
180. this could be the first
time our lead character dies to
close out the movie I don't think so but could be
[Music]
the next stop this is his here
what is going to be the domino effect with
this candy bar [__] like yo coming through
oh she's gonna get off and they don't that's
gonna be oh her sister knows her sister I
knew it didn't I say that damn you are you are
nailing this one you really are finally getting
credit where credit is due Emma's gonna cause
your death you intervened and it skipped us
why does death wait so long five months to
make them feel comfortable hey guys Julie
he's on the train damn it oh goodness
claim what's yours death how many of
them are gonna make it one two or three
none none none claim death yeah I think
this might be the first time they all die
Julie's definitely ooh claim
or is this another vision
oh Jesus
oh damn I guess it's just really happening
I was wondering if it was another like
premonition that would have been wild
because then they would have had to do this
foreign
ER but everybody you love is dead
what a train
it was a vision
okay something wrong they don't
have time to get off though yeah
what do you do [Music] it's not working
they're gonna just end it yeah oh spooky
spooky I got nipple chills at that ending
there yeah that was wild like actual Goosebumps
everywhere I I have to have to know Ryan Merriman
now that's the first thing we're gonna take care
of okay no but it wasn't him that was the guy that
was in the other movie I I need to I need to do my
due diligence right now you talk about the movie I
have to do my due diligence you're gonna okay well
because because for two reasons everyone wants the
newspaper movie and number two devil's voice was
Tony Todd oh yeah good cat yeah yeah yeah really
good catch we gotta get our Tony in there oh
um well what's your um my um did you
love it I like that one a lot most
it might be there okay again there are
things about the other ones I preferred
so you all of them are kind of even because
of that I I think that this one is the better
uh okay all right before I get the comparisons
out of the way I really liked uh Mary Elizabeth
Winstead a lot I love the main guy and I thought
this one did the things that I was wanting it
to actually do when you asked but I didn't think
they would just because I was like ah we're in SQL
territory now where they run a lot of tension it
was more reflective in between scenes like there
was actual tension when there wasn't scary stuff
happening and the two main characters at least I
thought were a markedly better Improvement than
the the prior film the the first one is probably
still the best mood in me but I love the look of
this film a lot I thought this film looked great
I was more connected with the with the couple
main characters though I was too but not not
necessarily in the first one but then the
second one yes Brian merryman was the guy in
um lack of the Irish and smart house
he did the d-coms that's why I know him
what movie did was there a newspaper that
you watched I gotta find that but I don't
think did you not see any of those decoms no
what's a decom Disney Channel original movie
oh I didn't have Disney Channel that was a
dude like none of those cheetah sisters or
like my High School Musical yeah I didn't have
to pass my time but okay well they were big like
I remember watching him that's where I I was
like oh that younger thing okay so that was
that and this other guy Jesse Moss let's see oh
Tucker and Dale Versus Evil He's the bad guy yes
that's a comedy you call it a horror film I was
like what's horror movie are you talking about
it's a hard comedy yeah okay I guess promotion
yeah I couldn't remember the name of it yes but
I was right yeah you were he was the bad guy
I couldn't get there but I was there and I
remember it was like he's either played a really
nice guy or a dog yeah wow wow okay I feel so
um satisfied right now like that was
great so okay oh I could not pinpoint
that it was bothering me too you made
me watch it and it is a newspaper Gray
he was a dick in the Evil movie with the
newspaper with the newspaper is like one
of the last things you would think of when it
comes to Tucker the newspaper that's all I can
remember billion other iconic moments I don't know
I can remember all you can pull is the newspaper
you couldn't even pull him I at least pulled
newspaper oh geez this is what happens to me
where I can't remember I remember weird moments in
movies I just I've always been like there's that
weird one line or moment that for some reason
stuck with me I just remember him presenting
the newspaper and US knowing like his parents
were the dad was the one that was the murderer
yeah that's all I forgot about that that's
the newspaper the newspaper tells us yeah
okay that's how I knew him that's how you
know you had questions about the the sister
right yeah yeah okay so let's Chit Chat
check the chicken out check it she was
um named Julie so she should be okay Amanda
Crew is her name no I did no I was thinking
she was Shannon's daughter she was in sex drive
she was in The Haunting she was in age of Adeline
yep never seen any of those all right all right
good talk that answers that um I still feel the
first movie had the best Ensemble overall but I
prefer the the lead characters here if that makes
sense like you isolate the lead characters in the
relationship and how that all formed I I was more
connected to that the first movie and and I I
bought more of the drama this time around whereas
like I was finding myself taking some of the drama
series I was taking the drama seriously and some
of the conversation scene seriously whereas in the
first and second movie they're kind of like cheesy
fun instead of me actually taking them serious
what I thought this movie was actually missing a
little bit of though was it it did kind of lose
some fun uh and not not I was never bored I was
never like not entertained but it did take itself
like really serious to the point where I I could
have used just a a tiny like sprinkles of of some
of that energy from the second one I S I see what
you're saying but I didn't feel that way I think
that this kind of was a perfect combination of
one and two it's probably my favorite one yeah it
might be mine too honestly because as I'm talking
I'm thinking about The Ensemble I actually maybe
preferred The Ensemble most in this I thought that
they were really good chemistry here and it is a
little they're characters across the franchise are
very typical I I know that the internet gets
annoyed with me when I say this but I'm just
gonna do it anyway because it's what I think a
lot of times like Angry woman or like dumb bimbo
or whatever even with like um the black guy
who doesn't believe what's happening and like
they it seems like they have their archetypes and
they kind of stick to it movie after movie which
um I think hopefully in the fourth and fifth
one we hear the fourth one's on third grade
hopefully they kind of like shake that up because
I would love to see not the like boyfriend who is
the nice one in the world and the girlfriend who's
super angry all the time whatever it is I feel
like we kind of are hitting the same character
types but the chemistry in this one I really
liked and the combo of there are two main leads
being maybe two of the more recognizable like in
this movie compared to the other ones they're very
good actors they did a really good job in this um
yeah just I liked this I liked I like the opening
of this I like um that they very quickly again
know they reference the other movie so they know
what's happening we don't have to spend a whole
hour figuring out like why are we is everybody
dying you know once the franchise decided that
they weren't gonna do that I'm I think that was
a really smart choice yeah I thought I think this
one is not as like the second one's more chaotic
like it it's a little bit more metal the second
one you know with the with the lottery winner
death the highway sequence the dentist scene that
one actually is I think I think the second one's
more violent too yeah definitely there was more
Gore in that one for sure yeah and this one it's
it's gory but it's definitely not as exploitative
Gore as I thought they would go I thought like
oh we're doing a part three we're gonna go even
crazier Heaven's pretty gross you know what's
weird but the third but the second one's like
borderline and saw movie you know with with the
way some of those deaths I feel like I I've liked
them more everyone then so I one I really liked
and two I liked it slightly more and three I think
is my favorite yeah that doesn't happen often
especially with a horror franchise yeah that's
cool that's cool that's cool man that's cool Final
Destination y'all did it I can't believe that you
got Highway to Hell and I got roller coaster in
love what's the let's see the thumbnail of the
what is the death if you have to pick one
death from this that stands out to you
what is it from not the franchise from this
movie uh hold on which one's the fourth one
is it remember they called it the five oh god
oh that gives me nothing on this poster oh I
don't want to find out well glass maybe yeah
but it could just be like a generic it would be
Heart of Glass yeah that's actually not a bad
call let's see what's the depth that stands out to
you the death that stood out to me the most here
I mean the one I'll probably remember the most
is the is the tanning booth one that's the one
that stands out to me the most too but that's the
one where they was they were really drawing like
everyone else's death correct me if I'm wrong
but everyone else's death is like domino effect
on effect they're dead whereas that one was like
suffering you know and I think that's that's what
the second one now why I say that's borderline saw
is because there's there was a lot more suffrage
that was happening with characters you know yeah
and and this one didn't really do that it was kind
of like watch DEATH do domino effect what'd
you call it what was the thing you said Rube
Goldberg Rue Goldberg yeah there's Guru Goldberg
and then and then they just die and there's some
like disturbing imagery but I do think the the
characters yeah they have like the ones that are
super like the two girls in the tanning booth are
like Beyond stereotypical uh the the but they're
still fun they're fun characters especially for
the time period it was very common like that and
definitely I thought it was yeah they were it
didn't bother me it was just like okay we get
it and I believe the the who was it mcclunky
McKinley McKinley yeah McKinley uh his his
ponderings that he would press I believed him like
that he they seemed like a it weirdly seemed like
a real character to me instead of let's give this
guy dialogue good to to reflect some of the themes
of the movie you know it actually seemed like yeah
I believed this guy I felt that way too especially
when he's like you know death is what happens when
the energy is the way like all the stuff I was
like oh I knew so many of you in high school there
you guys were like a whole group of um pretentious
yeah whatever that was but yeah I thought that
was really good yeah got those really effing
good this franchise is so solid what a bummer that
we hear the fourth one isn't great I'm excited to
see it anyway because I'm sure there are good
moments but like what if we walk away Santa
for like then death might come get us honestly
they're like no you don't deserve it uh but so
far this I mean this whole franchise is excellent
it's been really fun and I feel like this is the
one we took the most serious like I feel like we
kind of take the piss out of them a little bit
more but this one we were like I'm taking this
seriously which is a good sign actually who is
your favorite character in this in this one yeah
um I really like Mary I mean I I felt like Mary
Elizabeth Winsted actually had an arc because
she's very timid and she's closed off and then
by the end she's got like a set of friends
now and she seems like she's you could see
physically her transformation that she has grown
into someone more confident and that she has gone
through the grieving process even before she dies
yeah before she dies her death is like go [__]
yourself which I really loved I love the way how
they do kill off everyone in the end but I guess
there's just no way to really def I don't I still
don't get how can someone clarify that for me if
you made it this far how did the characters in the
second one defeat death but these guys didn't I'm
Gonna Keep looping back and looping back but that
didn't happen with the characters in the second
one it did they no it's remember moved on to the
little boy then I don't think he moved on to him
I think it's hitting them simultaneously I I'm
assuming they're gonna looping back to them and
the same with the characters in the first one
the little boy had nothing to do what do you
think death is because there's death I feel like
there's got to be like multiple Reapers because
you know people are 150 000 people are dying every
day like they said here at least in this world of
Final Destination 150 000 people die every day so
there's got to be like one Reaper's assignment per
case on something like this who's just has to you
know what I mean because that's more of like a god
scenario where they're overseeing a lot at once
you think there's one Reaper who's seen it all
right I don't think it's a Reaper I think death
death is like Oh you mean like an omnipresence
yeah okay and in the order and there's like
clusters okay yeah I imagine they're kind of
like a citadel of like death employees and like
someone's trying to make a good impression so in
the first one none of them are still left anymore
because the only Survivor the two survivors we
found out one of them died and yeah one of them
moved on to the next one yeah and the next one
the two people lived right yes and then this one
we're assuming she got smushed by the train oh
they all died yeah for sure so I wonder if we're
gonna get any of the two from two and four or five
maybe maybe David's Devin saw what actually is
alive I feel like they should I keep telling
you that's really how I kept it I mean you
got a lot right this time so I'm gonna lead
I'm gonna go with the fact that I think you
might be right but I could be wrong I do love
the ending here of how she has the premonition
again and death is just like go to hell because
we think the way that the premonition works
this time I'm like oh they killed them all
and then I'm like oh they didn't so I think
we're in the clear I think we're gonna stop
it and then they're like ah sucker I I look I
think the second movie's Highway sequence is
masterfully executed I do I think though but
that one is just so crazy this one felt like
this could really happen like that what happens
here on the roller coaster that is a fear of mine
and you know you've seen news reports where
yeah they are just stuck upside down and like
it's happened to people and and some terrible
tragedies have happened on roller coasters before
yes on planes and highways as well but there was
something about this one that other than like he
happens to grab the dude when he's you know grabs
the I forget the black Jock's name whatever his
name is um he grabs that guy other than that
everything else was like this seems very real
and there was such a tension to it like the the
highway one was like crazy and fun this one was
like this is truly scary what's happening right
now that was actually like the highway one wasn't
scary to me the highway one was really fun this
one was I am I am literally like scared of what's
happening the reason I think I liked this opening
the best is because we see car accidents in movies
all the time even though this was on a grander
scale and we do a lot on the road like even with
yeah yeah sure you know just franchise movies
just even this year right there's like a lot of
car chases a lot of car accidents just so much car
stuff same thing with plane crashes we do see a
decent amount of it even with like lost and yellow
jackets and um of course in movies too or like you
think the plane's going down I can't recall seeing
in a movie a big roller coaster accident yeah and
I think that's re I think the roller coaster to
make Mary Elizabeth Winstead's character so much
about uh someone who has this fear and this sense
of this need to control when you put them in a
situation where you have no control like there's
some semblance of you can at least move around
on a plane yeah but on a roller coaster you are
locked in and trapped in a situation like that so
I love the thematically to line up her character
with that as well I just think this one's shot the
best too I think out of all three of them this
one looks the best of them it felt like it had
a bigger yeah yeah like cinematography I wonder
if it was the same cinematographer actually or
if they went with somebody new well James Wong
directed the first one and then he came back
for this one so they use the same person that
they previously I feel like he refined his work
um but no overall man I thought I think this is
a this is a really I really like this one a lot
I was I was really impressed with this one what's
your ranking I think right now I would have to go
it's impossible to beat the freshness of the
first one right it's impossible to beat that
oh it's Robert McLaughlin who did Game of Thrones
Lovecraft this one um the cinematographer oh wow
did a few episodes of Ray Donovan he's done a lot
of the shows that we like he did 1923 oh damn he
did 1923 yeah um that's yeah he's DP'd a lot of um
Great West world oh sweet interesting interesting
okay sorry you were in the middle of talking when
I interrupted you to do that oh you interrupted me
with important information but the facts nothing
but the facts but we got to get you out of here
yeah because you got to go to your your ground
all right so then let's give a special shout out
well I mean we should wrap up all right
a little bit more too you know okay well
all right let me say the stuff leave a like
comment make sure you're subscribed be here
for our next one hopefully if you guys like
this video we continue watching the franchise
um and make sure that you make it
safely to your final destination
of Heaven one day not today
hopefully a long time from now
okay bye in the shadow and it's oh yeah and
a shout out what's going on to who I think we
should do uh Daniel Gallagher but I liked what
you did before where you did this Boston acronym
thing oh okay cool so I think you should actually
give it a nurse who Daniel gallacher sounds like
an Irish guy from Boston [__] Daniel Gallagher
dude all right Daniel here what do we got D is for
uh D is for Duncan donkeys you got
America runs on Duncan you know A is for
Angels in the Outfield which is baseball
which Red Socks we got there n is for
Newton it's where I'm from I did that last
time but you know sometimes you just got to
go back to it I is for Icy it's so cold there
in the winter it's just ice on the ground you
got to make sure you have your salt to put it
on the ice e is for England comma new because
it's in New England because that's where
Boston is and the L is for let's [__] go
Daniel Gallagher there we go
thanks for being a patron honestly
um you are the sexiest of the rejects and
that's the title that you've earned today
how'd we do uh I think there was no we it was all
you thank you oh good okay uh we'll see you guys
next time for Final Destination four yeah might as
well might as well find out how terrible it is I'm
nervous about that one I think we already have the
lowest expectations yeah so it could be good it's
a means to an end the fifth one's supposed to be
good okay yeah so fifth one some people say it's
the best and we'll cover that in like four weeks
when you're back from Boston yeah sorry okay bye
foreign